l'intelligenza artificiale se ne parla
veramente tanto
anche la speaker di prima cristina molto
più brava e molto più esperta di me ne
ha parlato infatti una tecnologia che in
tanti dicono ci può cambiare il mondo
il punto è come ce lo può cambiare e
quando voi ne parlate vi sarete accorti
anche voi che tipicamente chi ne parla
si divide in due grandi gruppi i
pessimisti e gli ottimisti partiamo
dagli ottimisti
ad esempio io sono stato invitato a un
evento sull'intelligenza artificiale
alla bocconi un po di tempo fa qualche
mese fa dove prima di me hanno parlato i
grandi player quelle aziende che stanno
investendo tantissimo l'intelligenza
artificiale vedete i loghi dietro di me
non sono abbastanza chiare google
facebook microsoft così via tutti quanti
dicevano che l'intelligenza artificiale
ci farà vivere in un mondo bellissimo
questi sono speaker autorevoli sono
aziende molto importanti però devono
vendere anche i loro prodotti di
intelligenza artificiale
allora io voglio portare un esempio
ancora più autorevole e questa e fei fei
l'ikea felice fili è una bravissima
ricercatrice di stanford dell'università
di stanford che lavora per utilizza per
creare dei sistemi di intelligenza
artificiale che riescano a far capire
alle macchine le immagini cosa c'è in
un'immagine in un ted di qualche anno fa
lei dopo aver spiegato quello che fa la
ricerca che fa ha finito con queste
frase che vi mostro lì
l'intelligenza artificiale aiuterà la
medicina aiuterà i dottori aiuterà gli
infermieri nel loro lavoro aiuterà le
auto a guidare in modo più sicuro con
meno incidenti
addirittura ci aiuterà a salvare le
persone ferite nei grandi disastri
purtroppo sappiamo che ce ne sono sempre
di più e ha finito con una frase che a
me piace molto tanto perché addirittura
lei diceva in questo ted diceva
l'intelligenza artificiale ci apre a dei
mondi che neanche ci possiamo immaginare
delle frontiere addirittura invisibili
naturalmente non tutti la pensano così i
primi pessimisti come diceva giustamente
il nostro moderatore il nostro speaker
sono proprio i film di fantascienza come
diceva infatti questo è proprio un
immagine tratta da 2001 odissea nello
spazio dove questo almo questo computer
hanno hl una lettera meno di ibm dotato
di intelligenza artigianato della qual
cosa fantastica invece poi alla fine ha
ucciso un astronauta qui almeno l'altro
astronauta è riuscito a disinnescarla
venderlo innocuo nell'ultimo il più
recente film ex machina invece il robot
la ragazza al robot prende il
sopravvento sulle stesse persone che
l'hanno creata ma sono film di
fantascienza non hanno non hanno una
base vera e propria scientifica però
anche giornali autorevoli come supernova
portano questi titoli
un giorno un intelligenza artificiale
controllerà il mondo e qui non sono più
il film sono degli esperti che lo dicono
o ancor di più un quasi premio nobel
come di tutto rispetto come stephen
hopkins dice beh l'intelligenza
artificiale diventerà più forte delle
persone addirittura fino ci sarà il
rischio che decreta la fine della
razza umana adesso io qui non voglio
prendere parte di una delle latino di
fare in questi pochi minuti che ci
restano vorrei fare un breve percorso
con voi per vedere un po cerca di capire
assieme che si può veramente fare
l'intelligenza artificiale e dove invece
magari ci resta ancora un po da lavorare
e incominciamo con quadratini che
probabilmente molti di voi ne ha sentito
parlare perché effettivamente
ultimamente ha dato dei risultati che
qualche anno fa erano totalmente
inaspettati il famoso di turno
l'apprendimento profonda in realtà di
profondo dal punto di vista concettuale
filosofico non ha molto per cui profondo
se si riferisce semplicemente a strati
magistrati sono quelli gialli con i
pallini gialli che vedete nella
diapositiva ma chiamarla apprendimento
astratte sarebbe stato molto meno
accattivante ma partiamo dai puntini blu
di questa rete neurale perché alla fine
è una rete neurale che esisteva anche
tempo fa scusate non partiamo da quelli
rossi quelli rossi sono le cose che io
l'input le cose che io do al calcolatore
ma il caso ad esempio di fedeli e le
donne immagine bisognin immagine che è
fatta di pixel ad esempio l'immagine di
1024 x 1024 pixel quei puntini rossi non
solo 45 come sono lì sono più di un
milione e sono dei numeri per i pixies
sono i livelli di grigio
poi ci sono i pallini gialli i pallini
gialli sono delle funzioni parametri che
però è come se fossero delle manopole
che si possono regolare al fine di far
sì che i pallini blu che danno la
risposta diano la risposta giusta
ad esempio se io do un immagine di una
giraffa
alla fine il panino blumi dovrebbe dire
che leggerà afam all'inizio e poi
pallini gialli sono messe a caso e mi
dice ad esempio che un cavallo allora
esistono delle tecniche per regolare
questi pallini gialli in modo che mi dia
veramente che una risposta giusta una
girata
ma se ne do un'immagine sola appena una
diversa non capisce più niente questa
rete neurale
allora cosa si fa sia destra la rete
neurale addestrarla non è una cosa così
strana semplicemente si inizia a dare
tante immagini per ogni immagine di
giraffe e si dice che quella una giraffa
e quei pallini gialli si autoregolano in
modo da dare la risposta giusta è
proprio quello che ha fatto fei fei lì
con grande coraggio quei tempi ha
cercato ha trovato miliardi di immagini
miliardi di immagini adatta trovato un
modo col crowdsourcing di farsi di si
dice di taggare di dire che quelli erano
tutte giraffe e a quel punto se mi va
avanti ecco mandiamo avanti bene ea quel
punto la rete è diventato molto esperta
non l'ha fatta solo le giraffe era fatto
con tutte le immagini i cavalli e le
zebre ma con tutte le immagini che
potevano esserci ma allora a quel punto
aveva ragione fifa e lì o aveva torto
aveva effettivamente ragione questo è un
articolo del new york tardi un po di
tempo fa che dice in india proprio
queste tecniche con le reti neurali sono
analizzate tantissime immagini di retine
si è capito si sapeva quelli che sono
retinopatie man si addestrati delle reti
tanto potente che adesso possono aiutare
il dottore anzi forse tanti dicono che
sono ancor più bravi dei dottori quindi
effettivamente aveva ragione pfeiffer lì
però c'è ancora qualcosa che manca a
questa vita ad esempio io se devo
spiegare un bambino che la prima foto
che vedete lì
una giraffa o un modo di spiegare il
guarda che collo lungo che ha e magari
dico guarda che l'ultima non è un
cavallo perché alle strisce bianche nere
una zebra
ma la rete neurale queste cose non le sa
perché la differenza fra la girata una
zebra è un valore in quel puntino giallo
che sono una miliardata di puntini
gialli che 0,7 invece che 2,1 e non era
una spiegazione
quindi si dice che le reti neurali sono
delle black box e io quando vado al
dottore mi dice guarda che tu rischi di
ammalarsi di quella malattia una
spiegazione da lavorare ma
l'intelligenza artificiale può solo
analizzare immagine può fare molto di
più ad esempio può creare delle cose
sì una tecnologia che ultimamente ha
avuto molto successo sono le non so se
ne avete sentito parlare di queste le
gang degenerativa di rossa reali al
netto sulle reti generative avversarie
adesso vediamo perché si chiamano così
la figura sembra complicata ma non line
quella parte rosa che dire di c'è
scritto discriminatore una rete neurale
come quella che abbiamo visto prima
e anche questa viene addestrata come
viene addestrata con tantissime ad
esempio immagini questa volta facciamo
immagini di volti di persone
poi c'è un'altra rete che il generatore
generatore invece una rete vedete il
rumore genera immagini a casa come
quella fake i magi uno sgorbio e allora
però al discriminatore viene addestrato
per imparare capisce benissimo la
differenza fra l'immagine di persone e
quelle fake i magi quelle immagini
generate a casa ma un certo punto di
simulatore quando è stato ben addestrato
dice un po modo un po superbo io ho
finito quindi sono molto bravo allora
parte il generatore il generatore genera
un'immagine a caso ma la manda al
discriminatore facendo finta cerca di
fregarlo facendo finta che sia
un'immagine di una persona ma il disco
minatore che vengono addestrato dice no
ragazzo questa non è un'immagine di una
persona ma gli dà anche una cosa di
dalla distanza quella che i tecnici
chiamano allo sfalcio la funzione di
perle di quanto ti sei sbagliato
e allora adesso inizia generatore
imparare ea cercare dalle immagini
diminuendo sempre più quella distanza
fino a arrivare un punto a una distanza
tanto piccola che frega il
discriminatore di scrivere dice sì
questo è generato e l'immagine di una
persona e guardate che cosa riesce a
creare andiamo avanti ecco queste sono
persone che non esistono le ha create
proprio l'intelligenza artificiale con
quelle tecnologie
ora se uno guarda bene la ragazza agli
occhi un po strani no quindi non è
proprio perfetto ma forse anche proprio
il fatto che non è così perfette che la
rende ancora più vera quindi
l'intelligenza artificiale può creare
cose ad esempio può creare quadri questo
quadro non è stato dipinto da nessuno è
stato creato dall intelligenza
artificiale da questa tecnica e
naturalmente è stato venduto a una cifra
abbastanza interessante ma siamo ancora
un po distante del robot di cui parlava
prima anche cristina che vanno lì
agiscono nel mondo allora il ricercatore
di intelligenza artificiale hanno
utilizzato queste tecnologie per creare
qualcosa in più per non solo capire le
immagini ma anche addestrare un'altra
rete come quella che vedete sotto che
una volta che hai capito che hai davanti
un predatore come quello che c'è lì
riesce anche ad addestrarsi a fare
l'azione migliore
e se sono una preda l'azione migliore è
quella che c'è scritta di runaways k
allora uno può pensare di fare un robot
che in realtà è una preda che scappa
davanti a un prenditore ma naturalmente
può pensare di fare anche l'altra cosa
di fare il predatore che azzanna la
preda e questo è un po più paura ce lo
può fare tenete presente che questa
tecnologia che si chiama apprendimento
con rinforzo perché proprio cercando di
agire nel mondo che impara questa
tecnologia è esattamente quella che è
stata utilizzata per sconfiggere il
campione di google è un gioco molto
difficile la cui origine non è del tutto
chiara ma una delle ipotesi è che questo
fosse una tecnica che utilizzavano i
generali cinesi addirittura nel medioevo
con delle mattonelle chiare delle
mattonelle scura per pensare come
attaccare l'avversario come circondarlo
e da un gioco dove tu devi vincere
contro l'avversario innocuo come go a
alla guerra dove tu devi sconfiggere il
nemico il salto dopo tutto non è così
lungo infatti il pentagono ha svelato un
pò di tempo fa abbastanza recentemente
l'idea di un progetto dove loro da un
diario di combattimento lancio dei
piccoli droni che si autoregola con del
tecnico di intelligenza artificiale per
colpire meglio il nemico e questo è un
po paura
la fa e se pensate i soldi che ci sono
investiti in intelligenza artificiale in
questo periodo veramente questa può
diventare una tecnica sempre sempre più
potente nel bene e nel male ma allora
detto questo cosa dobbiamo fare nel per
il futuro dobbiamo essere tranquilli ma
dobbiamo essere pessimisti
io credo che sia importante essere
consci dei pericoli che porta
l'intelligenza artificiale per farsi di
portarla verso un intelligenza
artificiale che fa del bene
ad esempio se noi pensiamo ad esempio di
prima a quella famosa black box che non
spiega un lavoro che si può fare che
stiamo facendo ad esempio come ricerca
in fondazione con i colleghi cercare di
renderla scatola nera una scatola bianca
che si spiega e guardate con cosa
facciamo con la vecchia cara logica che
piace tanto ai filosofi noah da socrate
in poi perché la logica mi dà un modo un
modello per farsi di vincolare la rete
nel modo che apprende è anche nel modo
che può fare
e allora se si usa questa si può cercare
forse cercare di fare dei sistemi che
aiutano l'aereo mentre a terra a essere
in più sicuro possibile sappiamo che se
n'è molto bisogno oppure a guidare un
robot sotto il mare per controllare le
tubature di un oleodotto modo che non si
spacchino e non lo inquina ma per
rimanere molto più vicine a noi si può
utilizzare l'intelligenza artificiale
per aiutare i bambini ad andare a scuola
a piedi riducendo l'inquinamento delle
macchine e questa non è fantascienza
questa è una cosa che si fa a trento ci
sono in trentino e ci sono un migliaio
di bambini e 800 in emilia romagna che
stanno utilizzando questa tecnica oppure
questo mio ultimo esempio far sì che
tramite un atto medico un dottore
esperto ad esempio di diabete
invece di ordinare di prescrivere una
ricetta elettronica cartacea che sia
prescrive un pezzo di software per
scrivo un piccolo sistema di
intelligenza artificiale che chi soffre
di diabete se lo può scaricare nel
proprio smartphone nel proprio tablet in
modo da gestire nel modo migliore la
malattia 30 persone e lo stanno
utilizzando in trentino in questo
momento ma il nostro piano è quello di
farlo utilizzare a migliaia di persone e
mi piace
ecco una cosa importante dello stato ed
enti qando in trentino per una scelta
chiara
i dati che servono per addestrare questi
sistemi di intelligenza artificiale non
sono di google non sono di facebook non
sono di amazon non sono della provincia
autonoma di trento non sono della
fondazione di un'orchestra sono della
persona nel senso che la persona si può
utilizzare per il suo bene e per finire
mi piace finire con questa frase sempre
del grande steven coatings
l'intelligenza artificiale può essere
una cosa meravigliosa una cosa
bruttissima sta a noi sta a noi a tutti
noi dai ricercatori ai cittadini a chi
lavora nelle imprese a chi lavora nei
servizi pubblici pubblici cercare di
indirizzare l'intelligenza artificiale
verso il bene grazie
[Applauso]